now the 8 news now i-team asking why
state troopers are being paid less than
their counterparts good evening to you
thank you for joining us at six i'm
brian loftis i'm denise valdez and last
night here at 11 o'clock we showed you
how the lack of troopers may be
affecting our safety well now we're
looking at why there are so few
applicants signing up the i-team's david
charns live above i-15 right near the
strip with the major differences in pay
and the governor's promise for a wage
hike david
as the abuse now i team first told you
here last night there are some times of
the day when just three or four troopers
are patrolling the entire las vegas
valley they're patrolling roads like the
busy 15 freeway here behind me so we
wanted to dig a little deeper into this
tonight finding out why state leaders
say candidates simply aren't applying
yes we do have a problem yes yes it is
very concerning concerning because the
lack of men and women patrolling
nevada's highways could mean more danger
on the roads the very viability of our
state police is in jeopardy because of
lack of personnel those comments during
an interim meeting of a legislative
committee in december
we have shifts day shifts that have six
troopers working the valley as the 8
news now i-team reported monday nevada
state police highway patrol is having a
rough time retaining employees and
attracting new ones overall we are well
over 100 150
positions short
hiring has been extremely difficult
applications are few and far between
pay and retirement benefits are big
reasons why more than 20 percent of a
trooper's salary is automatically taken
out for retirement a state law requires
an employer to cover a police or fire
employee's retirement contribution but
the state of nevada is exempt data from
the state lets us compare area police
salaries a sergeant in henderson can
start at one hundred thousand dollars a
year compared to eighty one thousand for
metro and fifty five 000 for state
police in my almost 29 years law
enforcement i've never seen this before
wayne dice is with the nevada state
police union he says at least 30 union
members most of them troopers have left
the department this year that's led to
nights when just three or four are on
the road patrolling the entire las vegas
valley our state police make less than
most municipal officers in his state of
the state address last month governor
steve sisilak promised to raise state
police wages when the legislature
returns to carson city i will be
proposing a salary increase so we
guarantee that nevada state police are
well trained and well paid the board of
examiners which the governor chairs
approving a new collective bargaining
agreement for the police union with a
two percent retroactive pay bump but
that can't start until next year at the
earliest this is an issue that has to be
addressed right now because every week
that goes by
we have more people leaving
and the union estimates about 30 of its
members many of them troopers have left
since the beginning of the year they
also tell us that the department has
reassigned some troopers that were on
the dui task force to cover some of
those overnight shifts and two troopers
are now working on yes recruitment we're
live above the 15 on d-i i'm david
charns live local now